you guys accuse your management of abuse
and mistreatment i think we trauma
bonded for me it's felt a little
vulnerable but also powerful to be able
to talk about that
first of all congratulations
the way you guys have me scream singing
in my car to love back
i'm not even kidding i'm like if you're
not gonna be the one at least give me
back my love
yes
you still got your fingerprints left all
over my heart the same way
[Music]
talk to me about the video because you
guys did something really special for
this visual that also involved your fans
right yeah yeah so we did a show at the
lra probably three weeks ago in l.a it
was like a secret show it was the day
that love back actually dropped on all
platforms and we were like we want to do
something special for the fans we're
gonna do a secret show and like put out
a little rsvp just to people you know
like it was it was very like kind of not
talked about and then we went around la
that day and like surprised fans like
actually and gave them tickets to the
show and they had no idea what was
happening they were told it was like
gonna be for like some documentary about
us and they were gonna answer some
questions but they didn't know we were
showing up so we were actually like
walking up the reactions you see in the
video are real and then we got to give
them tickets to the show and one of the
girls we got to go in her house and like
hang out and like play on her keyboard
and like sing along it was amazing she
was actually a really good singer yeah
not to mention you guys are rolling
around in vespas i mean how fun was this
show i thought the best was mistake
until i literally ate it
me and corbin were like fully standing
on the seats like up on the spot yeah
and i'm i i'm not even kidding it ran
out of gas while i was up like that oh
and so it started slowing down a little
and it crawled out and go
home and flew off like it's on camera
too i guess when it runs out of gas it
just just stops
i think that i think it made a clip in
the video
they do their own stunts folks they do
their own
intentional well that night you guys
mentioned that concert it was your first
show in like over two years i mean how
emotional was that how special was that
for you to be like the last soundtrack i
almost cried yeah it was timely i wasn't
terrible in the back there was a point
where it felt like we genuinely might
not perform again during covet and yeah
that was like the toughest reality to
face and so doing a show again was like
i don't even know how to describe it it
was so all the emotions came back it's
like our identity comes out the most on
stage and it's like ourselves
it's like oh this is what we're supposed
to be doing yeah yeah
well when you're
loved back to that same like day yeah
the fans already knew it too it was like
wow the lyrics yeah
well that's because they're so catchy
speaking of your fans you know i got a
chance to watch the video and it was
clear that they were excited to see you
guys back on stage too they've been
going hard for you since 2016 when why
don't we form what does it feel like to
have that special bond with them it's
like nothing else man yeah the bond
between
an artist or a group of artists and
their fans is it's sacred and it's
special and it's very
resemblant to like family
and
you know they're our lifeline and
they've literally done everything for us
we would not have this life without each
and every single one of those people and
i'm just eternally grateful and i just
want to get more music out for them
because that's all they've been begging
for lately
i just every artist says this but our
fans are genuinely like yeah yeah like
actually no job like sorry they're
actually
[Applause]
[Music]
it is such a bob it is so catchy but
then when you actually listen and read
the lyrics you're like oh damn this is
kind of heartbreaking you know you're
it's like good for you i've been bopping
that lately and i'm like crying
well yeah instead of crying in the
shower you're just kind of scream
singing like i said you know i think
taylor swift coined the phrase it's like
the hair brush song where you're singing
it from the mirror and just
right and this song really does mark the
beginning of a new era for you guys
especially after a difficult year for
the band i'm curious does this song take
on a different meaning for you you know
knowing all that you guys have been
through together in the last few months
yeah i mean it was absolutely
it definitely does
definitely been through a lot it's been
a crazy year
it plays love with time and it it just
it's a whole new song
my time back i just want my time
uh
no it's it's been good and just to
finally get the green light and like be
able to put music out again yeah
the fight definitely isn't over as to
you know our statement and everything
that's happening we're definitely making
strides in a positive direction and for
sure we just love seeing the fan support
and everyone coming around us and
supporting us has been the best feeling
in the world obviously in early
september you guys accuse your
management of abuse and mistreatment and
in the statement you wrote why don't we
as more united and determined than ever
to fight for our freedom how has this
experience brought you guys closer
together you know we were talking about
this yesterday at lunch quite literally
where
and in all honesty i was like i think we
trauma bonded
i said that to the guys and genuinely i
think
mentally
even physically at the time we were in
such a crazy tough position that
we bonded through it in the weirdest way
and
you know just yesterday i was like what
if we just went to like the beach
together and did something like normal
together and that's like new for us it's
this really new healthy
relationship we're working on where like
we can we can just bond in some normalcy
love back is the first song that's come
out since our truth has been spoken to a
certain extent and so that song
definitely does take you know even more
of an importance in that sense because
it feels like hopefully what's the first
step in the right direction personally
and mentally and and even just for our
fans and even for the industry man like
we're not the only case of of that type
of stuff happening for me it's felt a
little vulnerable but also powerful to
be able to talk about that and
i just hope that you know throughout all
of this that if anybody is going through
something similar whether it be in the
industry or not that you know there's
that we can provide at least a sense of
of hope to some extent for
um you know for anybody going through
rough times when things like this happen
i feel like there's that same word they
don't happen to you they happen for you
right like there's lessons to be learned
what would you guys say is the biggest
lesson you learned about the business
but also yourselves that you'll like
carry with you moving forward because of
this um first of all just be a good
person
it's that easy too yeah it seems that
simple right yeah yeah
like never never doubt yourself never
give up yeah
surround yourself with
people that you genuinely
trust and love and don't waste your time
on the other people
honestly it sounds selfish but it's like
worth it
and i don't think that that's wrong
to do that well you guys obviously you
have so much cooking up this is your
chance what do you want the fans to know
about this next era why don't we and
what you guys have planned for the
upcoming year we got our foot on the gas
we got right
the car doesn't have brakes yeah we got
we got a bunch of music in the vault
ready to go we have a tour that's
mostly planned
fingers crossed we can go home
and uh yeah a lot of exciting stuff on
the horizon so stay tuned this is
is is ready to go right it's no stall
this is revved up i love it well listen
fellas congratulations i'm telling you
this song i can't get out of my head so
i can't wait thank you thank you next do
you know any can you give any hint and
when the next single is going to drop or
before next year perfect next year
love it
[Music]